poino on it for Minnesota in behind for gdo back
to Felino in the circle his shot was blocked
Merill holds his own Merrill's long shot gloved
by they're prone to leaving Guys open so the
more patient the wild are in the offensive zone I
think the higher quality chances they'll get zukar
second shift for Minnesota's Top Line favor a long
shot then score it was tipped out front by Rossi
and Minnesota leads it one Z favor with a quick
shot Rossy again left alone out in front beautiful
little backhand tip changeing Direction like the
positioning there too enough distance from the
net goal scored by a rookie assisted by a rookie
in Brock Faber and Minnesota leads one- Zer Rossy
fires again and a glove save by morazzi nagoski
knocked off the puck behind the Minnesota net an
whistle has it for Chicago Dickinson defended
by Durer plays it out to the line a long shot
got through Saed by flurry out to the line a long
shot deflected out front picked up in the corner
by Johnson around for Bard back to the line
for Jones now Bard Johnson tried to go across
for Kev who was sneaking in on the back door
Bard has it again Johnson fires from a sharp
angle and that's deflected up and out of play
by see some of the numbers on the Minnesota
penalty kill they've been perfect over two games
some of the deeper analytics tell you it's not
a fluke here a loose Puck furry crawling back
and it's deflected out to the line Jones holds
Blackhawks have had a couple good looks on
this power play Bard moves in fire saved by
flurry rebound loose flurry trying to find
the puck still alive and the Blackhawks come
up with it with Berard Bard centers tipped on
goal saved by flurry attempts and high danger
chances that was not the case on this kill it
was simply flurry Brilliance yeah they lost
their their form a little bit there getting
broin shading to that goal line attack Side
Chicago set that up that zuk Carell tried to go
cross ice bagosi Manning the point with Spurgeon
out with an injury classic in short-handed
cuts to the middle and a save by flurry boldy
carries back for Minnesota Johanson to gdo gdo
moves in finds some room fires on goal saved by
morazzi Rossi got it out to
Faber at the line g r Rossi
scores
Conor who the Minnesota rookies on the board
twice it's two zip wild as they win this Puck B
it goes High Chicago forward on their horse to
get out down low then the pop Chicago forward
cannot recover in time there's enough room
there Rossy presents his stick Chicago gets
lost a nice little finish from Marco Rossi
for his second on this offensive zone draw
AE saw WI the puck battle centered it
just out of the reach of zukar Spurgeon
to gagoski into the middle capriso across
they score what a feed to zukaro and it's 30
Minnesota and as it works its way up to the D
watch capristo work to get up and he directs
traffic he says hey go D to D he knows he wants
to pick this up on his forehead he also knows
where he's going with it before he catches it
picks it up in stride puts it into a passing
spot finds the lane slides it over flat with
a little spin beautifully on the tape of Matt
zukar and Jones intercepts well just a lot of
room in the neutral zone I mean he can come
out two on one here Baldi moving in fire save
moric rebound and Capri off was denied by a
kick save from the Chicago golender Puck over in
the neutral zone to get up the ice quick so it's
a quick regroup into Bal going on the attack two
onone here tries to shot and then that bouncing
rebound just over Baldi stick to flurry has it
for Minnesota leaves it for Merill Merrill spins
away from radish walks right out front of his own
net def Flex right on goal where morazzi tees it
up Rossi with a shot glove save by mazig Rossi
with a good look off on the for che one man for
check here he just SP spins the defender around
and then takes it off of him finds zarella One
Touch pass to Marco Rossi kinsky the guilty
party turning that one over Eric s tied up by
blassic got it to Baldi in behind now for caprisa
out to the line Spurgeon zuk Carell takes a look
fire score Baldi got a piece of it on the way it
appears and the power play goal has Minnesota up
by four gell in the spot he holds on the power
play because he makes the right decision more
often than not he's given the shot there he's got
a lane he puts it in a spot where his teammate
out front can do something with it that's boldy
off the stick nice tip well that's not an easy
tip either body facing the net three in a row
against the central nine in a row against the
West capriso carries in it's a three onone capriso
fir save bazic and broin didn't get much on that
rebound chance that created the three on one
kof decided shot was the best course of action
rebound up to the free and zuk gell each had
a crack at it the amount of space that this
group needs to create a play is getting smaller
and smaller two onone for Chicago the other way
and a sliding save by flurry two saves on
22 shots reserving the shut out for now for
zip Bard in behind for Tyler Johnson cev pressured
by Felino radish in behind Tyler Johnson out to
Bard Bard looking back for Johnson tried
to Center Rish with the flection and he
scores Mark Andre flurry I don't think there's
going to be goenda they go high to low the wild
GE running around a little bit Jake Middleton his
job there long body seal the cross eyes pass he
doesn't do it gets through him catches radish
off the backside skating in Maroon shot good
row on the rebound looking for Felino was tied
up by Murphy Felino still down in the Chicago
crease good row with it fires hit traffic out
front maroon with a shot p s moric Minnesota's
had a road heavy schedule so far this season
there's only two teams in the league that have
played fewer home games than Minnesota and when
you consider that Eric Sak here stopped by mazic
that one of what technically counts as a Minnesota
home game was played in Stockholm against Toronto
they've played nine games here in this building
coming into today that would be tied for the
lowest number of games in a home ring for any team
in the league and they've got a four game Road
Trip coming up well that sets up well for them as
they trying to climb the west standings Baldi got
it to Spurgeon and a save by mazic baldi's had a
couple of those here tonight nice pickup spinorama
leaves this one for Jared Spurgeon looking for his
patented SP short side glove good communication
there maraz well there's confidence on display
right there too you got three-goal lead your
fourth Line's on the ice closing out the game they
approach the Blue Line they're confident enough to
make a play two steps in but they've earned that
confidence a thorough Domination by Minnesota